i spent a lot of time
making myself technologically
uh
able let's say
but
my health is impaired now so that's a
problem but i find it difficult to keep
up there's so many things to keep up
with and changes take place so fast
just as you adapt to one thing
another thing comes along and it's like
that with everything your computer
changes your refrigerator changes your
car changes right in front of your eyes
it's updating all the time and so your
knowledge is continually outdated
so you you know you work very hard to
develop expertise with something and all
of a sudden it's completely different
i found that very frustrating with
microsoft word
you know i really knew the programs and
then they changed the menu it's like
well i spent like 10 years practicing
how to use that i really knew it it's
like well now the menus changed and so
all that knowledge is gone and so
and
we have no idea what this intense focus
on social media
is doing to everyone but particularly to
young people
i mean can you imagine
that
nothing you ever did with as a teenager
could be forgotten
i look can you imagine that god
i mean i also look at it from the from
the perspective of hiding but you know
hiding behind the phone and i live in a
world where people have said horrible
things about me on the internet and on
social media yeah that's funny yeah it's
so fun i know you have a lot of
experience with that but i don't know
them so i can write that off to
they don't even know me right but now
this happens in school and a kid can
read this and and they they're in class
with that person or they they have a
locker near them and they're like is
that true then and i think that that is
such a dangerous and
horrible thing for a kid to have to deal
with i very much empathize with kids
today and social media
and just
you know we haven't even talked about
pure body image and just pure looks i
mean you don't know what anybody looks
like anymore
through social media and filters anymore
either but but definitely from at least
like a
acceptance standpoint
when people say things yeah well one of
the things i've been concerned about
is that
so there's a there's a female pattern of
antisocial behavior and there's a male
pattern of antisocial behavior
and the male pattern of antisocial
behavior is a lot more physically
violent
the female pattern of antisocial
behavior is reputation destruction
yeah
yeah and it scales on the internet
see physical aggression doesn't right
right what can you do right it's limited
and i'm not saying it's not serious it
can obviously be
mortally serious right it's serious but
it does characterize it a small minority
of men especially
consistently
but female antisocial behavior which is
almost never discussed there's a large
research literature on it
because people have wondered you know
that if you look at boys and girls for
example
two-year-olds i mentioned them some
two-year-olds are aggressive and that's
by nature mostly
okay so they kick hit bite and steal
in groups of two-year-olds now they're
not very harmful because they're two
but if it doesn't if it isn't socialized
it turns into conduct disorder and that
turns into anti-social criminal behavior
that's what happens
so most people who are criminal by the
time they're 18 were aggressive when
they were two and weren't socialized
okay so now most of those aggressive
two-year-olds are boys
if you define aggression by hitting
kicking stealing and biting
but the reputation destruction that
starts early with girls and that's their
form of antisocial behavior
and you know
we don't know what political
manifestation female antisocial behavior
will produce
because
the
complete immersement of men and women in
the political realm is new
but for to think that it'll be nothing
well you have to be a complete bloody
fool to think that because obviously the
dark side of men has a dark political
edge why wouldn't the dark side of women
have a dark political edge
so
i know you know there's no discussion
about that at all to speak of
but i can't help seeing it i see it i
think that's the reputation destruction
that's characteristic of social media
seems to be i mean i saw
when girls went after my daughter in
particular when she was a teenager
bullying on on social media they use
reputation destruction and it can be
unbelievably vicious while you said
you've been attacked plenty online
wow
huh so do you so the social network
being as it is i mean well we look at
you know chrissy teigen or people like
that i mean women
have definitely been on the fire for
things that have happened
on social social media platforms
hmm i wonder if it's more men than women
then
well that's a good question that would
be a good place to start the research
like i don't know who now it's also
possible that
you know there's a large proportion of
men who use reputation destruction too
online
so
i wouldn't say that this is something
limited to women by any stretch of the
imagination but i do know that those two
patterns of antisocial behavior exist
so and that one doesn't scale so that is
a relevant issue
so
you were talking about asked about body
imager commented on body image too you
know we could talk about that a little
bit if you'd like yeah absolutely a lot
of people think that that's a
consequence of social pressure
body image trouble and i don't think
there's any evidence for that by the way
really yeah well a lot of so
women are more likely to have body image
problems than men right okay so that's
the first thing
so
and that's likely because
body morphology is more important in
mating choice
for women than it is for men
men tend to prefer women who show signs
of fertility that's associated with
youth
and symmetry
so symmetry is very very important as as
a marker of beauty so we tend to see
symmetrical faces as beautiful waist to
hip ratio 0.68 that seems to be
relatively standard culturally
regardless of body size
and that's also that's associated with
cardiovascular health and with fertility
and so
there's an ideal
idealized ideal female
morphology and any deviation from that
causes upset and women are more prone to
negative emotion than men not anger by
the way
that's that's a tougher one
but
anxiety and pain related emotions women
are more sensitive to those than men
maybe because they're smaller and
life is more dangerous to them and they
have to be more threat sensitive
maybe because they take care of infants
and so you know one question i've never
discussed this i don't think on online
women become
more sensitive to negative emotion than
men when they hit puberty
not before
and it never goes away after that
right so it's a permanent transformation
even after menopause just like
yeah well the men and women get more
stable emotionally as they get older but
the difference between men and women
doesn't seem to attenuate
and so i've now women became sex become
sexually vulnerable at puberty so that
might be one reason why they would be
more sensitive to danger right
yeah right i mean there's plenty of
places in the world where you wouldn't
walk alone
sure right there's there's plenty of
places where walking alone would make
you a valid target even right right
right and i would say that's probably
more the norm for human societies than
the exception
you know we assume that our relatively
safe environments are
normal they're not they took a lot of
work to get safe
like so much work that it's almost
incomprehensible there's just so many
things we take for granted that make up
that safety
that are invisible because because it's
mostly there
but
i also wonder possibly if women's
nervous systems are optimized
for
the
woman child dyad and not for the woman
so imagine that well if you have a baby
you're definitely more vulnerable
right right and so perhaps your nervous
system should reflect that because
you're the one making the decisions
and you know because women are more
prone to anxiety disorders and
depression than men that seems true
cross-culture and it goes along with
that sensitivity to negative emotion you
think what's the advantage to that
because it causes a lot of suffering oh
it's no yeah it's terrible terrible it's
terrible
i would love to talk more about anxiety
when we get through this topic but it's
a it's crippling for people yes
absolutely well it's also a good promo
predictor of marital instability because
higher levels of negative emotion
predict well unhappiness so obviously
marital stability and or marital
instability but
it's certainly possible that women's
nervous systems adult women's are are
optimized for the for the child for the
infant mother diet
i mean why would we expect it to be
other than that you know because a baby
is so unbelievably dependent sure sure
so
so and and
well so there's all sorts of adaptations
that have to take place to that
you have to be more cautious once you
have an infant especially one under one
years old but even you know under three
under five for that matter
so then it comes into saying what what
is the point and so if anxiety comes in
if that is a
natural
um a biological shift once you hit
puberty yeah
for
precaution for self
as well as child yeah then let's then we
we know all the negative i mean the
negative side effects seem very loud but
what are the positives what are the
positives of anxiety well you're more
likely to stay away from danger